[Music]
last summer an FBI agent was pulled from
Robert Muller's special investigation
into Trump makes sense Peter struck
seemed there had exchanged anti-trump
and pro-hillary texts with a mistress
who was also on Miller's team that's
evidence of bias and let's face it
stupidity struck also had interviewed
top clintonites Huma Abedin and Cheryl
Mills as well as overseeing the probe
into Michael Flynn which raises this
bias test if Flynn's lies wanted a
charge
why don't whom isn't Cheryl's it's a
good question especially when the same
lawyer also changed a vital phrase in
commis statement about Hillary's emails
grossly negligent my nickname became
extremely careless that small change
reduced Hillary's actions from criminal
to merely incompetent and that
ironically preserved Hillary's
nomination helping pave the way for
Donald Trump
that's pretty hilarious if you're not a
Democrat you should be really angry so
do these revelations mean Muller's probe
is biased maybe but this whole thing
went from being about colluding with
Russians to anything involving a Russian
if you rooted for Drago in Rocky four
then you're guilty I did and it's
obvious that the media craves something
really big they want a holiday ham from
Muller but so far all I got is a fuzzy
breath mint look at them losing their
colluding minds I think they're shocked
that the noose is tightening cuz I don't
know if they were arrogant or just
incredibly unselfish and really dumb
about like what the job was about how
important it was and how under the
microscope every move you made would be
I think they just thought they'd go in
there and flim-flam and riff through it
you know I think they're shocked that
the noose is tightening that people
might go to jail you're exactly right
the rest of their lives for the rest of
their lives they're so cute when they're
nuts
you know what this is it's called a
fainting couch you both need one you
chuckle buckets but now we actually do
have proof of collusion not between
Trump but Hillary's camp and the FBI
ignoring that would be grossly negligent
all right we got some breaking news here
Jesse uh Judith from Judicial Watch I
believe the new Justice Department
records show strong support
Andrew Wiseman who was a molar deputy
showing strong support for what st.
Betsy Yates
Sally Sally Yates her refusal to it I
like Sally or Betsy good breaking news
that refused her to endorse the travel
ban and he said my deepest respect to
you I'm so proud of you and that's a
person working for Muller yeah so he
praised her for defying Trump's travel
ban which is funny because the Supreme
Court by seven to two margin just upheld
it is constitutional so both of those
two individuals are partisan and they're
at a step with the Constitution they
didn't uphold it as constitutional they
said you can't put it in place in the
middle of my brilliant commentary you
can take it up with me when I'm finished
all right it's always correct so and
they fought hard the team Muller three
bonus communication from the public now
Weissman is an extremely controversial
individual he has a reputation for
rule-breaking for withholding evidence
for threatening and intimidating
witnesses and I think the Houston bar
called him a madman now the two major
prosecutions of Wall Street firms Arthur
Andersen and Merrill Lynch he completely
botched one was overturned by the
Supreme Court nine nothing the other was
overturned by the fifth District Court
of Appeals so the guy has a track record
of prosecutions and convictions being
overturned he's maxed out to the Obama
campaign and he's a partisan pit bull he
doesn't belong anywhere near an
investigation now Muller also another
investigator Janeen Rae maxed out to the
Clinton campaign representing the
Clinton Foundation represented Hillary
personally when she was fighting the
email thing so just imagine if the shoe
is on the other foot Gutfeld and you
have prosecutors investigating Hillary
and they're Trump donors or they worked
for the Trump Organization and they're
sending text messages about crooked
Hillary
make America great again you think the
Democrats would take that line down no
I'd hope they'd have two pair of shoes
because I don't want her tripping you
know Kimberly there's a lot of piece of
in a lot of pieces of information here
that may seem small but they add up to a
pattern of bias you have emails with
these emails with a mistress and get
overlooking Huma and Cheryl they're
adjusting language to help Hillary
that's a lot of stuff no it is and that
and what you're talking about is
aggregating this information when you
put it together it makes quite a
compelling case that there was a very
much lack of objectivity so there was
inherent bias in the investigation and
what's shameful is that they would put
people that are so partisan that have
made actual financial contributions and
have them be part of an investigation of
someone that they do not support and
have gone out of the way to put their
money where their mouth is and say okay
I'm against this person then plus the
language the text messages the emails
and Sarah Carter told Sean Hannity last
night that through her sources there are
more emails coming out to show the bias
here and that they were really kind of
out to get Flynn and President Trump
then candidate Trump at the time so this
is exactly what you don't want from
anybody involved in an investigation or
you know injustice now that's the
problem here so you can't just blow it
off and say oh well who knows no when
you add it up it means something
significant yeah yeah okay T this is
collusion how far does it go probably to
the top well and that opens up all kinds
of questions about the Clinton email
investigation which we've all had
sitting around this table questioning
what the extensive nature of that
investigation was why is it that the
inner circle that played around Hillary
Clinton was able to have immunity why is
it that Cheryl Mills is allowed to be
both a witness in the case and also the
attorney for Hillary Clinton and one
thing that jumped out at me today is
that the Justice Department is not
commenting on any of this so it must be
a very awkward place for Jeff Sessions
to be in for his staff to be in because
they're the ones who have to answer to
this as well and they have a problem on
their hands when it comes to Special
Counsel and broad Rosenstein who
appointed the special counsel is the one
who's going to have to really look at
this and go we do have a conflict of
interest here and it's not that you
have political opinions Washington DC is
a one-stop shop for for politics that's
what people do there the problem is the
conflict of interest and clearly there
has been one on multiple occasions in a
variety of cases imagine though for what
you're saying if President Trump wasn't
elected and sessions wasn't the AG can
you imagine that you might not ever hear
about but here's the the fun part waters
you got you gotta love this if struck
hadn't struck those words she wouldn't
have been the nominee and you might have
had a president Sanders and you would
have been laughing for the rest of the
year on the five let me tell you Gregory
I laugh a lot let me just tell you the
news today because of course you're not
going to hear it here folks but the news
here robert muller has now documents
from deutsche bank here's a second thing
to tell you right that's what one of the
guys working with Manafort ties to the
Russian Secret Service right again we're
getting closer but what oh it's all
about some silliness with an FBI agent
guess what they have opinions they have
political beliefs which among us wasn't
tweeting Gregory in the midst of the
president's meeting in the midst of the
printer viewing you can do your job you
can come in here and have your job and
then just like mr. sprock do well then
here's my question then because of
entire reason why Jeff Sessions as the
Attorney General of the United States
recused himself from the Russia
investigation is because he said there
was a conflict of interest because of
his involvement in the campaign would it
be okay with you for him
not to have recused himself because he
might have political opinions about
Donald Trump but he can still do his job
even though he was on the campaign no no
no he was personally involved Katie in
other words he's even had to come back
what got mine but he says no no no he
was actually involved this agent this
agent had a political opinion and was
doing his job as an agent you guys now
are attacking law enforcement when it
comes but not while you're trying to
shift the argument away from the obvious
collusion between Hillary's campaign the
FBI there is no such thing you're trying
to shoot us away from Donald Trump and
the fact that after the Flynn plea and
guilt admission of guilt to lie that as
you heard from Micah oh my gosh I mean I
think the noose is tightening well no
the noose is time yeah I just say the
noose is tightening or is that like a
micro graphic I don't know is it a ban
phrase yeah people who've died by
lynching but here's the thing Jesse the
point is these the noose is tightening
they're actually lowering the bar for
what they want first they wanted
collusion now they're looking for
obstruction of justice they're probably
not going to get that they've had been
investigating collusion for two years if
they had found collusion it would have
leaked by now they haven't found
collusion so now they're trying to build
an obstruction can probably try to
impeach this guy now let me just go back
to something you said yeah I don't have
a problem if someone's donating to a
Democrat or donating the Republicans and
they're the lead prosecutor going after
a gun manufacturer or a large
corporation or through an Indian
Reservation or something like that this
is politics this is so much more serious
than you know just some sort of
corporate prosecution or wall street
prosecution they're going after a
political campaign the winner of that
political campaign is now the President
and prosecutors are donating to her
opponent and giving different treatment
to different people based on their
politics that alone raises the question
of has the integrity of the
investigation been compromised where and
has the team been compromised there's an
old saying one I know you are who you
hang out with oh that would make mole
John painter okay so what is that what
does that make me a bunch of
troublemakers we hang out okay so that
makes me therefore p.m. wild-eyed
conspiracy theorists like you know I
don't think let's just say I'm not sure
we're friends
Oh colleagues I'm going to tell you it
doesn't make a difference trunk donors
investigating Hilary you woulda raised
huh I'm sure there were because guess
what you sure you've got a sure love all
put a spray hey not so sure there were
Oh what
I'm tired of guessing what guess what
that's why guess what we're gonna go to
a tease or